what is Alice an FPS relationship like
this this season in season three yeah
it's it's getting more and more
interesting
well that really a lot of the most of
the parents and the kids are brought
together by this series of events that
starts to happen that is was part of our
upbringing and is now part of our kids
lives and so we're brought together for
those circumstances and and obviously
carrying all the the heat from before
all the rest in the history and
complications will we see more of Polly
and the twins the season yes yeah there
was a teaser that was released where
Polly and Alice hold the babies over a
fire and it's all around the the farm
and the Colt and everything that so
we'll see what happens with those babies
yes I don't know will she one hopes hmm
one hopes although there are benefits of
this part there are benefits of his arm
yeah for sure we've experienced some of
that what is Penny's relationship like
with Effie we don't know right away
obviously it would not be good and I'm
looking forward to getting into that I
think Britt's so talented it's fun to
work with her so I'm curious to see how
that starts there's another fan theory
that Alice and Penny are sisters ooh and
I like the idea that I could see that's
kind of cool yeah yeah like she's a
sister that went bad wrong yeah I like
that theory to them is this season gonna
be as dark as last season yes yeah
darica yeah it's uh it's it's different
but it is a mystery that kind of
involves everybody so it's it's turn
like we've we've had the murder mystery
in season one
we have the serial killer looming in
town now we've gone into some like evil
territory for season three could jelly
bean and jugheads mom be making you know
what you've done that looking every
interview generic like ultimately I know
deep down you're excited too
yes no I wasn't anything some yeah
they'll be coming amazing is there gonna
be another musical episode Roberto said
yes yeah yeah that's as far as we know
that it's only no no flashback well I
just I just hope I'm not included again
because that was that was I'm ready Gary
okay you can take over yeah oh I'll
cheer you on if there's no audience
Pearl Jam covers yeah okay rock and roll
F pain right I like that I mean scary
but fun right like a good job it was fun
it was definitely a good challenge I
don't know if I'd want to do it again
but but but I never say no so when
whatever Roberto you know proposes I
always say yes in her own way
Marisol seemed up for the challenge yes
I can't sing I can kind of thing depends
on this know she can sing she could for
sure sing yeah she's a little like Joan
Jett rock and roll like attitude yeah we
did it we did a season one rap party
where a bunch of the cast got up on
stage and saying their favorite songs
and performed and she got up there and
sang Joan Jett she rocked it that was
like her she like sealed the deal yeah
yes Queen yes tell us about the new
characters Edgar and Evelyn ever and
ever
well we haven't met the actor that's
going to play Edgar but he is a very
sought after elusive character so we
will eventually meet him um Evelyn is I
just had a scene with her and she's nice
and creepy yeah she's
what is alice's involvement in the farm
she's just homemade she drank the
kool-aid she's all in
she's just searching for for healing and
to try to find some reasoning behind how
she didn't know that her husband was a
serial killer
so she's just looking for closure